في صوره نمطيه انه رائد نعمان لازم تكون
صغير شاب تعرف اللي
تشوف المتوسط العمر تقول اوكي هذا شخص
اوكي يعني نهايه الثلاثينات وطالع لانه
وقتها مر بالتجارب واستوعب ان الموضوع ما
هو بظهور اعلامي مو سلام جوائز ما حد يعرف
ايش فائدتها مو ايموجية اتفاقيات الموضوع
لازم يؤدي عمل فيه
[موسيقى]
يلا حيهم ضيفنا اليوم مصعب الحكمي وهو كان
تذكرونه اول ضيف استضفناه في برنامج قبل
اكثر من خمس سنوات في الحلقه الاولى اتكلم
ضيفنا عن تجاربه في بزنس الدجاج
والمقاولات والمخابز شطح الموضوع حقه
بعدها صار عنده كاش وبدا يستثمر في
الشركات التقنيه الناشئه الى ما وصل عدد
الشركات اللي استثمر فيها تقريبا 118 شركه
المنهل نجح طبعا منها فشل ومنها اللي ما
زال ينمو الى اليوم فبسولف اليوم مع ضيفنا
عن تجربته في الاستثمار خلال السنوات
الماضيه كيف اختيار الشركات اللي استثمر
فيها في من مختلف دول العالم كيف يوصل
للفرص المميزه وشاب رزل الفروقات في الدول
اللي استثمر فيها وغيره من خبرته في موضوع
الاستثمار بشكل عام نسولف ايضا عن وضع
السوق الحالي ولا ايش انخفض تقييم كثير من
الشركات الناشئه وايش الفرص المتاحه اليوم
ليبيس شركه ناشئه جديده وش المجالات اللي
ممكن يكون في تركيز اكبر عليها خلال
السنتين الجايه وكيف اراد العمال يقدر
يتعامل مع المستثمرين بشكل جيد يضمن
للحصول على استثمارات
بشكل عام بغطي مواضيع كثير بتفيدك خاصه
اذا كنت مهتم في الاستثمار في الشركات
التقنيه الناشئه او في تاسيس وتطوير
الشركات الناشئه بشكل عام فاترككم الان مع
الحلقه حياك الله اهلا وسهلا كيف
الامكانيات التسجيل الجديده
[ضحك]
الفرق الكبير اللي صار الحين اتوقع شيء
هائل يعطيكم العافيه
يعني هذه الحلقه غير انه بنستفيد من خبرتك
فيها برضو تحسين سمعه شوي
خلاص انتهى الموضوع فوقتها كنت تشتغل في
الدجاج كنت تشتغلون المقاولات دخلت برضه
في
المعجنات المخبز اللي سويتها بعدين
بالنسبه للناس على الاقل
في فجوه صارت فجاه صرت مستثمر في عدد كبير
من الشركات فبيعرف بس لو ناخذها تكمله بعد
ما انتهت تجاربك تتوجه للاستثمار في شركات
ناشئه اصلا طيب بعد التخرجات الاخيره شركه
الدواجن
والمصنع والمخبز اللي صار بعدها كان في
سيوله
وحاولت اني استثمرها في اكثر من مكان عملت
وقتها في جهتين حكوميه في بدايه الرؤيه
ولكن بعد اكتشفت اني انا عند ما زال شغف
في الاستثمار
وبدا السوق ينمو في قطاع تقنيه المعلومات
او الشركات الناشئه التقنيه بشكل ادب
وقتها بديت استثمر على خجل في شركتين
ثلاثه قعدت احاول اتعلم واكتشفت في وقتها
وفي لحظتها ان في فرصه كبيره جدا في السوق
هذا ولكن احتاج اطور نفسي كمستثمر وهنا
تعرفت على مصطلح استثمر ملائكي
فبعد الاستثمار في مجموعه من الشركات كان
عندي رغبه اني اسرع العمليه بس قبل ما
نسرين العمليه ليش
لان الهدف الاخير اللي ابغاه مقارنه
بالوقت اللي بحقك فيه ما راح يجيب لي اياه
العائد في في الاصول الثانيه
اربعه مليار دولار اوكي
احتمال
بالاضافه اني انا ما املك فيه اي خبره
صراحه يعني انا مهندس حاسب
فافهم التقنيه
واستثمرته بنيت شركات اعرف كيف تبني شركه
صغيره شركه متوسطه فهذه الاثنين اذا
دمجتها مع بعض تطلع لك شركات الناس متوجه
لشيء عن المخاطره بس العوائد صح
مقارنه بادخل في سوق ثاني ما عندي اي خبره
فيه
فبتورط ممكن
اكثر من 80 90% حلو في المال ويستثمر في
شركات التقنيه من عام بديت الاستثمار
نهايه 17 تمام وقلت له بعد اتعرف على
مصطلح
وكان عندي رغبه في تسريع عمليه التعلم
فنقلت الى
سنه تقريبا هناك
استثمر واتعلم واقابل الناس واشتغل مع
الاستاذ واحذر
مؤتمرات واحضر
حقت اول العروض عروض الشركات فكل هذه
يساعدني اني اتعلم خلال هذيك الفتره
استثمار في مجموعه من الشركات هناك مجموعه
شركات هناك مجموعه من الشركات هناك في
امريكا مجموعه شركات في الهند مجموعه من
الشركات في السعوديه
ساري احد الشركات الاستثمرت فيها وانا في
امريكا اصلا
كانوا متخرجين من احد البرامج مسرعات
الاعمال وقابلت الشباب
كانوا في رحله تعرفت عليهم عن طريق مسرعه
هذيك الايام
واستثمرت معهم فسرعت لي عمليه التعلم بشكل
كبير جدا
الرحله هذه اللي ذكرتها بس وش استفدت
الاستفاده كان كلها من المعلومات اللي
حصلت عليها من خلال ثلاثه اشياء علاقاتي
صار عندي علاقات مع اشخاص
تجيهم الفرص الاستثماريه في المراحل
المبكره قبل الناس الثانيه بديت ابني
العلاقه مع الاشخاص هذولي استثمرت في
مجموعه من الشركات معهم هذه النقطه الاولى
النقطه الثانيه اني بديت اتعلم كيف هذول
الاشخاص يجمعون وليه يجمعونها بالشكل
الفلاني او ليش ما يسوون النقطه
الاستراتيجيه الاستراتيجيه الف
هذه الشغله الثانيه والنقطه الاخيره كانت
خبره المعلومات اللي اكتسبتها عن طريق
عن القطاع بشكل عام في المشاريع التقنيه
وين السوق متوجه وهذيك اللحظه انا اكتشفت
انه ممتاز انا كان عندي شغف بسيط بالماليه
في هذيك اللحظه اكتشفت التقنيات الماليه
ولهذا السبب تركيز كبير جدا وعدد كبير جدا
من الشركات الاستثمرت فيها شخصيا كانت في
قطاع التقنيات الماليه او الفندق حلو
هناك او كم موقع هناك
ادخل معاهم بشكل اكبر وقدرت اسوي هذا وهي
كره الثلج تتعرف على الستار الشركات
يعرفونك على الصناديق الصناديق يعرفونك
على الشركات وتدور الكوره هذه لين تكبر
كنت احضر اشتغلت مع شركتين اسبوع كل واحد
منهم بدون مقابل
بس مقابل اني انا اتعرف على اشخاص اكثر
اعرف ايش قاعد يصير حتى فتره فترات كنت
اركب اوبر بولينج اركب مع اوبر حيث يركبون
معك ناس عشان تتعرف عليهم بس من الشقه
اللي كنت ساكن فيها الى ابعد نقطه اقدر
عشان اتعرف على ناس او احد الاشخاص
بالطريق صحيح احد الاشخاص اللي تعرفت
عليهم كان سينير في بي في ليندن قابلته
بالصدفه في في احد
فهدتني بشكل كبير جدا في موضوع بناء
العلاقات والاشخاص تشارك اذا شافها تحت
شغوفه وعند الرغبه يتعلم ما حد راح يقول
لك
بعد سالفه انك رحت تستثمرت في السيليكون
كبير صراحه
كيف ان كثير من الشركات صارت تدخل تقول
اوكي هذا الشخص عنده مجموعه شركات
مستثمرها في السيليكون على سبيل المثال
كان في كمان شركتين او ثلاثه
يعني كان في حراك وكان في ناس سبقونا في
الموضوع يعني اس بي سي كان وقتها عنده
صحيح كان في بعض الصناديق بدت
تحصل على ارقام جيده من استثماراتها في
صندوق الاول فكان بدا الموضوع ينمو بشكل
واضح وواضح ان السوق قاعد يتوجه لهذا
الغطاء ولكن ما كان في تركيز على
خلينا نقول نموذج عمل معين او او قطاع
محدد فقط ولكن رياده الاعمال بشكل عام
والمشاريع التقنيه الناشئه كان في تركيز
كبير
عدد الشركات الاستثمرت فيها من بدات
الاستثمار ست سبع سنوات الان 118 شركه كم
نسبه الشركات النظريه اللي فعلا حققائد
انا استثمرت
ما يقارب 16 مليون دولار اللي هي في حدود
60 مليون ريال
تخرجت من 11 شركه منها رجعت لي اكبر من
مبلغ الاستثمرته في 118 كامله
في عشره فشلوا عشره مشاريع فشلت
والمتبقي ما زالوا الى الان ان شاء الله
انهم متوجهين
يرجعلك اياها للشركات الاغلبيه العظمى كان
نفس المبلغ دخلت فيه لسه ما تحرك الحين
بقيمه
لاني انا يوم نشرته بديت انشرها كان يعني
انا زاد عدد الشركات اللي استثمر فيها
بشكل كبير في 2021
فبدايه النشر كانت اغلب الاستثمارات هذه
لسه ما مر عليها حتى سنه
الباقي ما عرفت متى التواريخ
حقتني يمكن عده سنوات بس ما زالت شركات
يعني لا انا اقدر اقول من 118 شركه يمكن
75 77 شركه في اخر 18 شهر
حجم الفرصه كبيره يعني انت اليوم اللي
تطالع في الناتج المحلي في السعوديه ال جي
تي بي المفروض يكون اربعه خمس اضعاف يعني
تتكلم عن
الف مليار فانت المفروض يكون اربعه خمسه
اضعاف في المبلغ هذا معناها الفرق ما بين
اللي احنا فيه اليوم والفرصه اللي قدامنا
مرعبه فليش انتظر يجيني عائد وانا عندي
القدره اني ارجع واكمل في الموضوع هذا
ومازلت متمسك انه بس بكمل على شركات
الناشئه ثانيه الى الان ما زلت مستمر على
شركات التقنيه رغم من الفرصه برضه موجوده
في اشياء ثانيه لكن خبرتي تظل هنا
يعني تخيل انت تيجي تشتغل معاي في هذا
القطاع وانا وانتفس مو بنات انا مستثمر
ثاني نتنافس أنا كبيره علاقات كبيره هنا
بيساعدني الموضوع هذا في اني انا ما اقوله
افوز دائما ولكن تزيد احتماليه فوزي بعض
الصفقات
لو انا رحت في قطاع ثاني بلقى واحد عندنا
نفس الخبره اللي عندي في هذا القطاع
فاحتماليه خسارتي اكبر فحاولت اركز على
القطاع هذا واستفيد منه يمكن ما يبين
للناس انه مجرد توفر سيوله معك لا تعني
شركات ماشيه الشركات ماشيه تختار
المستثمرين معها ما انت على الاقل في
البدايه ما انت قادر تروح لاي شركه تقول
دخلوني معكم لو سمحتوا
المستثمرين الجيدين ورفضوهم صحيح
اللي بعدهم
الى الناس اللي عندهم فلوس اي احد عندهم
بالضبط غير مساله خبره انا يمكن عكسك بديت
تستثمر قبل
ثلاث سنين يعتبر جديد
واجهت صعوبه كبيره في الموضوع صراحه لازم
تكون سمعه لازم الناس يتذكرون انك انت
قاعد يعني بتستثمر مع الشركات
حتى لو ما اعتقدوا انك انسان عظيم ما راح
يجونك الشيء الثاني طلع الموضوع يتطلب شغل
كثير وهذا اللي ودي نتكلم فيها اكثر على
اساس يعني مجموعه اشخاص من ضمنهم سعدتوني
اني اوصل للاستثمارات جيده بس موضوع طلب
شغل كثير ما هو
بسالفه انه يا جماعه يا جماعه تعالوا انا
جاهز طلبات ادخل معاكم وانا وانا شخص كويس
وعندي خبره بيجون الناس فجاه استثماره
زينه نركز على الجانب هذه من ناحيه ايش
الاجراءات اللي تاخذها عاده
ما تجيك الفرص الاستثماريه الى ما تدخل مع
الشركه اذا كنت حتى نشرتها وكذا صريحه في
التويتر هذا ايميلي تكمي
الجيميل اي احد عنده شركه تقنيه
مواصفات معينه للشركات
هذه تعال كلمني اتصور فيه مليون واحد
اتواصل معك
في اول اول
اسبوعين تقريبا وصلني 2000
شخصيا عندي طريقه بسيطه للموضوع أنا
في اشخاص
ما يركز على قطاعات محدده ويصير كل ما
جتها فرصه يروح يبحث بهذا القطع
وهذه استراتيجيه قد تكون صحيحتك تكون
خاطئه كل واحد يعني
الاستثمار ولكن انا كنت افضل اني اتخصص في
في قطاع محدد جزء كبير منه كان تقنيات
الماليه لهذا السبب اطور نفسي فيه بشكل
مستمر بحيث اول ما تمر علي الفرصه اقدر
اعرف هل هي مناسبه ولا غير مناسبه
فانا كنت اجهز نفسي بحيث انه اذا جاني
مشهوره وجاني احمد او محمد او خالد وعرض
علي الفرصه اقدر اشوف هل هذه تناسب فلسفه
الاستثماريه هل تناسب توقعاتي للسوق اللي
موجود فيك ولا لا هذا الشيخ خلاني استثمر
بشكل اسرع وخلت اشخاص كثيرين يتواصلون معي
حتى اذا قلت لهم لا تكون لا سريعه بدل ما
اجلس اماطل فيه ثلاثه أربعة الكبير هذا من
الرسائل نفس الشيء جربت اني احطها مثلا في
لينك عشان يعز كبير جدا للش من برا
السعوديه حتى اللي تعال عندنا كذا
تعليم اشياء كثير مهتم فيها بعدين من ضمن
يعني من 500 رساله تلقى اثنين كويسين صح
اللي هم اللي تقدر تتكلم معهم نتكلم وش
تسوي مع الناس اللي ما تبيهم هل انك تسحب
عليهم
ثاني هل في اليه معينه للتعامل مع الناس
في في طريقه بسيطه انا اول ما يوصلني
العرض وهو احتماليه اكثر من 99% ما يكون
كامل التفاصيل الموجوده فيه فعندي تمبلت
جاهز قالب جاهز قالب جاهز
يرسل تلقائيا الاشخاص اللي يتواصلون معي
احتاج المعلومات واحد اثنين ثلاثه اربعه
وارسلها لهم
اذا رد علي بالمعلومات هذه ابدا انظر
للفرصه بشكل جدي هذا اول فلتر فلتر الثاني
وهنا ترى ما يتعدى الموضوع 30% من الشركات
ترد يعني اذا وصلت 100 ايميل وكلهم رجع
لهم القالب هذا رد الاليه او التلقائي
اللي انا احدثه كل فتره
30 يمكن في المئه منهم فقط اللي يرجعون
بالمعلومات عندهم جدية
بهذا الطريقه 70% من من الدين
فكره تطبيق ولازم توقع عندي ايه وهذا كلهم
طلعوا مجرد وصول للايميل لهم بعدها اشوف
القطاع هل هو يناسبني احد القطاعات اللي
انا افهمها اذا عندي وقت وقتها
وهو احد القطاعات اللي ما تهمني وجذبني
المشروع ممكن اربطه مع احد هو مهتم فيه
اذا ما جذبني ارسل لاقول له يعطيك العافيه
انا غير مهتم بالفرصه اذا هو في التقنيات
الماليه بشكل كبير بالذات في الفتره
الاخيره
احتماليه كبيره جدا يجلس مع الشخص واشوف
المشروع في حال ما كان عندي تعارض في فرصه
استثماريه ثانيه او في مجلس اداره او
استشارات مع احد الشركات في هذا غيرك ما
عندهم مشكله في الموضوع هذا
تعارضات معده شركات يقول لك انا ما اشوفها
تعارض عادي ادخل مع اثنين مع الثلاثه في
نفس القطاع او حتى متنافسين لان ما اشوف
انها تضر الشركات انت وش وجهه نظرك في
اعتقد صعبه جدا على المستثمر الملائكه
الفرد انه يقدر يفرق بين
بالرغبه ما بين الشركات فشخصيا ما افضل
اني استثمر في شركات تصير في تحيزات احس
لا اراديه طبيعي طبعا ممكن في صناديق
الاستثماريه يصير مختلف مسرعات الاعمال
موضوع مختلف لان في هيكله خلف الموضوع انت
نفرت شخص واحد هناك ممكن يكون الشريك
الاداري اللي يدير الملفك غير يشرك
الاداري ملف الشركه المنافسه لك انا في
الحاله الفرديه شفنا الموضوع صعب مره وشفت
ثلاث تجارب كلها كانت سيئه يعني ما طلعت
بشيء ايجابي في الموقع انت انت غالبا تدخل
مع الشركات في مرحله الاوليه
ما بيدخل في تفاصيل
المراحل الاستثماريه وصلنا نقول في مراحل
مبكره من عمر الشركه صحيح اللي الشركه
يمكن الحين ما نضج نموذج العمل غالبا ما
تربحيه يمكن حتى الايرادات توها ضعيفه
فهالمرحله كيف تتحقق هل هذه الفكره اللي
شغالين فيها فعلا او المنتج الاول اللي
يسووه فعلا بيحقق نجاح او لا المنتج
الاولي
مستقبل اولى لهم مستقبل هي تعتمد تعتمد
على توقيت دخولهم
يعني يجيني
احد
ادفع لاحقا خلاص
لان التوقيت غير مناسب
وجهه نظر ممكن يعني ما شاء الله عليها لكن
والسبب في نجاحها مو كان جوده التوقيت
ولكن جوده المؤسس نفسه طلع احسن من ما
توقعت انا
فجوده المؤسس توقيت المشروع وجود منافسين
من عدمه اللي هي جزء ايضا من جوده
المؤخرات من ناحيه
التنفيذيه خبرات سابقه يعني لو يجيني واحد
كم طوال فتره حياته يشتغل في في القطاع
الصحي وقرر يسوي مشروع تعليمي مقارنه بشخص
متمرس من قطاع التعليمي الاستثماري
التعليمي
بفضل الشخص الثاني لسبب بسيط وجود الخبره
هذه بتمنعنا من يعني الوقوع في اخطاء
كثيره نتفاداها
فخبره المؤسس تجاربوا السابقه في الشركات
الناشئه سريعه النمو
لان في شركات كثيره ممتازه وانا اقول لهم
لا هو يزعل يعتقد انه اني قاعد اقوله
مشروعك مو زين انا قاعد اقول له من وجهه
نظري تقييمك اليوم خمسه مليون المشروع ما
راح يصل الى 200 مليون دولار بسبب حجم
السوق بسبب خبرتك بحسب شخصيه الاشخاص في
اشخاص حذرين جدا ما عندهم الرغبه انهم
يبنون شركه ناجحه في خمس سنوات يبغى يقعد
15 20 سنه انا ما عندي ما عندي الرغبه اني
انا اشارك في الرحله
حل الموضوع هذا كنت تتكلم عن تخوف الناس
من شغلتين الشغله الاولى انهم يلمون
الشركه بسرعه يخافون من الشركه يكبرونها
بشكل سريع والثانيه انهم يوظفون استكه
منهم
في المنطقه هنا
ليش ليش يخافوا منهم الشركه المجهولهم
لان اذا لم الشركه بسرعه معناها غالبا في
المراحل الاوليه بيحرق مبالغ اكبر مقارنه
بالله واخذ وقته
وهو ما عنده خبره جيده او قدره فوق
المتوسطه على جمع رؤوسه مع الاضافيه فيخاف
خاف يمنه والسبب هنا قد يكون اما شخصيه
الشخص انه حذر بطبعه او عدم وجود خبره
سابقه في رياده الاعمال او في مشاريع
سريعه النمو لهذا السبب تشوف على سبيل
المثال كثير من مؤسسين المشاريع في اخر
ثلاث اربع سنوات كانوا يعملون مثلا في
كريم ليش لان الشركه كان سريعه النمو
وكانوا هم من اوائل الموظفين تجارب سابقه
فشافوا وعرفوا يتعامل مع الموضوع النقطه
الثانيه الا وهي الخوف من توظيف اشخاص
احسن منك
كثير منهم
مو بكلهم لكن كثير منهم للاسف
يخاف يفقد السيطره على العمل ويبغى يصير
مايكرو يدقق على صغيره والكبيره فوجود
اشخاص افضل منا في بعض الامور ما راح يسمح
لنا يدير الامور حتى لو حاول يديرها تبدا
يدخل في مشاكل مع الافراد هذولي فرغبتهم
في المحافظه على الطفل هذا لان كثير
مؤسسين يعاملون الشركه كطفل رضيع لسه ولد
او بنتهم يخافون عليها الا درجه يصير يصير
لمرحله انك تحميه اكثر من المفروض انك
تحميه احيانا خليه يبكي شوي خليه يطيح
خليه يزعل خليه جزء من التعلم فيتفادون
توظيف اشخاص افضل منهم مما يؤثر على نمو
الشركه يؤثر على تقييم الشركه يؤثر على
رغبه المستثمرين في الاستثمار وحجم
الاستثمار بشكل كبير
استغرب من النقطه هذه في النهايه
انت تملك في الشركه شخص خائف انه يستبدلك
الموظف اللي احسن من هذا
تحتاج مع الوقت انك تنمو يمكن هذه الاشياء
اللي عندهم منها انه ما يقدر ينمو هو مع
الشركه الشركه مع الوقت بس هو نفسه يشتغل
بنفس الطريقه اللي يشتغل فيها في اول او
ثاني سنه في تاسيس الشركه نتحكم بكل شيء
تفاصيل كل شيء ويشتغل بنفس الطريقه حتى في
نفس التكتيك نفس الاستراتيجيه اللي اشتغل
فيها في بدايه الشركه
ما افترض انه فيهم شوي يضغطون عليهم
يعلمونهم في في طاقيتي انا بلبسها طاقيه
الاولى بقول لك ليه
ولكن المشكله تصير مثل ما تفضلت نموهم
يكون ابطئ من نمو الشركه مو بسوء فيهم
ولكن نموذج العمل قد يكون جميل جدا الى
درجه انه ينمو بشكل سريع وهو ما عنده
القدره على النمو بالشكل هذا فهنا مجلس
الاداره اللي بشكل كبير المفروض يتدخل
ويقول تحتاج توظف
شخص في الف او في المنصب الف في المنصب
باء منصب جيم فهذه او هذا جزء كبير من دور
المجلس الاداره نظام مجلس الاداره ومجلس
الاداره
الشبكات اللي تكون فيها المجتمعات
الرياديه على سبيل المثال
اذا انت عندك مشروع تقنيه ماليه خلني اقول
دجه البنك او بنك رقمي وانت في شبكه على
سبيل المثال في اشخاص بنوا هذا النموذج
ونجحهم صارت مليارات دولارات تقدر
تستخدمهم وتتعامل معهم
كمرشدين لك وهم بيساعدونك تنمو ويساعدون
لانهم مروا بالتجارب هذه ودائما نجح فهو
مر بالشين والزين فراح يقدر يضيف لك ولكن
هذا كله ما راح يصير اذا انت كشخص ما انت
مستوعب من عندك مشكله وهذه المصيبه
الكبيره فيخافون يجلسون يقفلون على نفسهم
وعندنا امثله كثيره في المنطقه
كفاءات لانهم يبون يتحكمون
المتقدمه بس ما عندهم خوف عندهم ممكن عدم
ثقه يضطر وقتها انه يدفع رواتب اعلى من
متوسط السوق بكثير عشان يقنع احد يجي لان
السبعه تكون خربت
في عصر رقم متغير باستمرار المواكبه هي
اساس النجاح ولاننا رواد المستقبل الرقمي
نوظف خبراتنا وقدرتنا لنمكن نبتكر نبدع في
تبني احدث التقنيات وتوفير الحلول بكفاءه
وذكاء
[موسيقى]
كيف توزيع جغرافيا النص في امريكا
يمكن في حدود
في السعوديه والامارات
والفرق الباقي بينهم ما بين
امريكا الجنوبيه
في البرازيل وكم سوق ثاني والهند الاختيار
المكان الشركه يكون الاختيار اذا تكلمنا
مثلا سوق الموجود للشركه المؤسس الفريق
وكذا كذا كذا هل ايضا الدوله تلعب دور او
صحيح يعني على شركه مثلا كل العناصر
تتشابه مع شركه ثانيه لكن الدوله اللي هي
تشتغل فيها فيها فرصه كبيره جدا استثمرت
في شركه في المنطقه هنا ونجحت نجاح ممتاز
جدا الحمد لله
بعدها جلست ابحث ايش الاسواق المشابهه
للسوق لسوق المنطقه هنا
وجدت ان سوق البرازيلي في هذا القطاع قريب
جدا من سوق السعودي وسوق الاماراتي سوق
الخليجي بشكل اكبر
فرحت بحثت من في لاعبين يقدمون هذا خدمه
في السوق ما لقيت الا شركه واحده
رانشف بدينا نحصر
نموذج عمل ناجح سوق مشابه
عدم وجود منافسه تواصلت مع الشركه عن طريق
لينك بحثت عنهم لقيتهم لقيت المؤسس تواصلت
معه جلست اكلمك اقتنعت ان الرجال عنده
الرؤيه وشايف ان السوق جاهز انه ينجح لان
نموذج العمل هذا نجح في اسواق اخرى ففرصه
جاهزه اني استثمر فيها بالاضافه اني املك
خبر اني اساعده واقول وش الاخطاء اللي
ممكن يتفاديها لو بشكل بسيط حلو
كل الشركات كل ما زاد عددها كل ما صار هو
مرحب بفكره حصول على استثمار مني بشكل
اكبر الاختلافات اللي شفتها بين المناطق
اللي استثمر فيها هذه رواد العماله مثلا
في البرازيل عن مصر عن السعوديه عن
حجم الفرصه السعوديه مرعب
رواد الاعمال جالسين يتطورون لان السوق
كله على بعضه جديد في هذا القطاع بعضهم ما
شاء الله شفنا منهم يعني شركات تدفعنا
الان
عندك مؤسسينها كلهم يعني مرعبين ما شاء
الله بعض الشركات التجاره الالكترونيه
ايضا
فعدد المؤسسين اللي عندهم خبره سابقه في
السوق ما زال قليل والسبب عمر السوق لكن
لو تروح على سبيل المثال السوق المصري
وتروح السوق البرازيلي تروح سوق الهندي
روح سوق الهندي على سبيل المثال ابعد شوي
روح سوق الهندي تلقى شخص من
2011 وهو يشتغل
من 2009 هو يشتغل حتى لو ما كان مؤسسه
يكون موظف في ثلاث اربع شركات نمت بشكل
كبير وقتنا ان الان هو جاهز اني اسس
فتجلس مع شخص مر بالتجربه اكثر من مره
وهذا شيء ما تقدر
تستعجل فيها انت لانها تحتاج وقت الناس
اللي بيطلعون من ساري وتمارا وتابي وسله
وزد واو هالشركات كلهم مرسول وغيره
بيروحوا يؤسسوا مشاريع ثانيه
العمر ما يلعب دور مهم كيف العمر ما يلعب
دور مهم في الموضوع في صوره نمطيه انه
رادة نعمة لازم تكون صغير شاب تعرف اللي
تشوف المتوسط العمر تقول اوكي هذا شخص
اوكي يعني نهايه الثلاثينات وطالع الله
ابشرك بالخير
لانه وقتها مر بالتجارب واستوعب ان
الموضوع ما هو بظهور اعلامي مو سلام جوائز
ما حد يعرف ايش فائدتها
موز وتوقيع اتفاقيات الموضوع لازم يؤدي
عمل فيه ولو تلاحظ الشركات السعوديه خلينا
نتكلم الشركات اللي نمت بشكل سريع جدا في
اخر من 2019 تكلم ثلاث أربع سنوات بشكل
سريع جدا كانت غير موجوده والان تقييمه
فوق النص مليار دولار كل واحده منهم كانت
لاشخاص اما عملوا في شركات سابقه واسوا
الشركات سابقه
فالعمر هنا ما كان في مثلا الصغير عنده
النشاط وعنده الجلد اللي يقدر فعليا يسوي
فيه الشركه تدخل واحد نهايه
يبدا يبحث عن استقرار يبحث عن الهدوء يبحث
عن موازنه الحياه مع العمل من قطاع الى
لكن وطبعا في استثناءات لكل شيء في ما شاء
الله ناس على 21 22 احسن من اشخاص عندهم
30 سنه خبره ولكن بشكل اجمالي لافضل ان
الشخص يكون مر بعشر سنوات او اكثر خبره
عمليه نعتقد الفعلين التجارب العمليه اللي
تمر فيها هي اللي تشكل صحيح فاذا انت
اشتغلت في شركه ناشئه بتكون تركيباتك
تتغير بتصير اكثر نشاط اكثر سرعه اكثر كذا
في شيء ثاني
اذا عدى 35 في نهايه الثلاثينات خلينا
نقول والنصف الثاني من الثلاثينات وما
بعدها غالبا تكلفه الفرصه عليه عاليه
فبياخد الامور بجديه مئه بالمئه
يعني غالبا هو ترك وظيفه دخله فيها فوق
المتوسط علشان يروح ياسس هذه الشركه فراح
تكون عنده جديه عاليه جدا مقارنه بشخص توا
متخرج
فاذا ما ضبطت برجع تقدم الاحد برامج
الخريجين
مستوى تعامل رواد المستثمرين بين مختلف
اسوا مثلا امريكا هي الافضل يمكن شكلي
ارسال التقارير في التواصل مرعب بالموضوع
هناك يعني طبعا يفرق من مكاني الى مكان
يعني انا استثمرت في اوستن لسه
في ناس في المنطقه احسن منهم بكثير حتى
كمؤسسين مو فقط في التعامل لكن حجم الفرصه
في المشاريع اللي جالسين يبنونه كبيره جدا
مضخمه لهذا السبب الخلاني وما في احد قاعد
ينفسه لهذا السبب نعم ولكن بشكل عام خليني
اقول لك الترتيب قد يكون امريكا
بعدها في المنطقه بامريكا تحديدا
كاليفورنيا ونيويورك
ثلاثه بشكل كبير جدا
بعدها تجيك تصدق اولادك
بشكل عام سواء المؤ سعوديين او مستثمرين
او رواد اعمال جول السعوديه عشان الفرصه
الامارات دبي بعده يجيك السوق الهندي سوق
الهندي ضعيف جدا من ناحيه هذه تقييمك
من نوعيه التقارير
استمراريه التقرير جوده التقارير تفصيلها
توقعاتهم كميه الاخطاء مقارنه بالتوقعات
اللي بنين عليها البزنس خلال سنتين
له كلمتها
يعني في البدايات يتكلم انت في مراحل
اوليه جدا الشركه لسه فيها من موظفين لعشر
موظفين وكان معاك مستثمر عنده خبره افضل
شخصيا انها تكون شهريه لاني ودي اساعدك في
اشياء ممكن اساعدك فيها ولكن انا راضي بكل
ثلاث اشهر
كل ثلاثه شهور ممتازه
وش صار في البزنس من ناحيه ارقام مبيعات
عمليات غيره شو الموضوع التجاري موضوع
التقني وين وصل
لحل التقنيه اللي موجود
موضوع المالي كان باقي في حسابك كم حرقت
كم وظفت كم تعتقد التغييرات هذه ممكن تاثر
عليك ومتى بتجمع جوله بناء على المبالغ
اللي موجوده عندك
ونقطه اخيره دائما نسميها
اسوا الاشياء وافضل اشياء
اللي قاعده تصير قول انا وش افضل شيء صار
وعلمني وش اسوا شيء
ممكن اساعدك هل تعتقد عدم ارسال بعض رواد
الاعمال التقرير هذه تخوفا منهم متباع
الناس من رده الفعل من الاشياء هذه او انه
بس مش فاضي ارسلها بكل بساطه اعتقد انه ما
عنده اخبار حلوه ارسلها لك مو معناه ان
عنده اخبار شينه
اللي تسعدك اعطيتني استثمار او مبلغ غض
النظر كم المبلغ في برضو من تجربتك في
شركات انت فعليا اشتغلت معهم اكثر من انك
تكون مستثمر فقط وش الشركات اللي كنت تقرر
تقول مو بشرط حتى اذا ما تبي تصديرها بس
هو الشركات اللي تقرر تقول هذه بشتغل معها
بس بنصحهم ومن بعيد لبعيد
يعني في شركات مثل ساريه معروفه صح اشتغلت
فيها الفتره وبعدين طلعت واشتغلت على
اشياء ثانيه تقول لا لازم اشتغل معاهم
حجم الفرصه
يكون في هذيك اللحظه وضح بشكل كبير جدا ان
الان وقت مناسب
اني ادخل واساعدهم لانهم يحتاجون خلينا
نقول مؤسس اضافي غير موجود عندهم الى الان
تاسيس فريق الماليه بشكل كامل تاسيس فريق
تجاري سواء مبيعات وتسويق وغيره فاذا هذه
الاشياء فيها نقص اقدر انا اتدخل معاهم
طبعا برضاهم بطلبهم غالبا اني اساعدهم اني
اسس هذه الاشياء بس اتصور تطلب وترفض
وش اللي يخليك تحكم فعلا في النهايه وبروح
مع هذولي هل انه اكيد في شركات كثير تحتاج
نفس الاشياء اللي ذكرتها هذه بالضبط سواء
كانت هي فرصه ضخمه ولا فرصه يعني اقل منها
نسبيا
فذكرت معيار مثلا المؤسسين
غير كذا كلهم يحتاجون
صح لكن الفكره اني هذه اللحظه المناسبه
اني انا ادخل معاهم وجودي
واصلاحي وبنائي لهذه المواضيع راح يساعد
على نمو الشركه بشكل كبير جدا في وقت قصير
فانت قيم كم هذه ممكن حتى يرفع العاده
صحيح فاذا في شركه مثلا دخولك
ثلاث مرات ومرتين تقول اوكي
وبعدين متى تقول اني لا خلاص بطلع الحين
بروح اذا صرت اقدر اغيب عنهم ثلاث ايام في
الاسبوع خلاص تحسن اسست فريق والامور
استقرت ليش
قاعد تستثمر بشكل فردي ولا انك استثماري
مؤخرا طبعا
متخصص في تقنيات الماليه
ليش ما جيت ابكر لاني اعتقد اني تمكنت
بجزء اكثر من 50% من المرحله اللي كنت
استثمر فيها بشكل فردي فالان وصلت الى
مرحله عندي ثقل كامله اني كل اللي يحتاجه
راس مال اضخم
بحيث اني اقدر احصل على عائد اكبر اراكم
من خلال الفتره القادمه ممكن يتعارض
ملائكه كبير جدا يتعارض لهذا السبب في
حوكمه واضحه عن طريق الصندوق جميع الفرص
تمر على الصندوق اولا
اوكي جميع الفرص تمر على الصندوق وانا
اصوت عليها
ولا لاحقه
في حوكمه واضحه يستحيل اني استثمر في فرصه
قبل الصندوق وانا اعرف ان الصندوق بيدخل
فيها صندوق ياخذ الفرصه اولا بعدها سواء
قبل فيها او رفضها اذا قبل فيها خلاص انا
عندي استثمار عن طريق الصندوق ما راح ادخل
فيه بس اشكاليه هنا بالتعارض
مليون دولار من روس اموال الاشخاص اخرين
معناها بستثمر اقدر اغير واخذ اسير مع
شركه اخلاقي
فاتفادى يعني
لهذا السبب الان التركيز بشكل كبير على
الص
ندوق ما اتوقع ما تحسن الصناديق
كبير موجود اليوم هل تعتقد انه فعلا السوق
يحتاج الى هذا العدد اللي موجود لان
[موسيقى]
عدد الفرص الاستثماريه متغير فانت في 2019
كان في صعود جدا لعدد الفرصه عدد الشركات
الناشئه اللي تاسست بسبب وجود شركات سابقه
حصلت على تخرجات
2019 2020 صار في نمو مرعب بالاضافه الى
رؤوس الاموال اللي دخلت السوق الان في
تباطؤ بسيط ممتاز ما هو بشكل كبير لكنه
بسيط تعديدا في السعوديه
الشركات وصناديق الاستثمار عمرها مو سنه
ولا سنتين غالبا صندوق عمره من ثمانيه الى
12 سنه
فراح تجي ويب ثانيه موجه ثانيه تصاعديه
موظفين مثل ما ذكرنا ساري وتابي وتمارا
وسله كلهم بيطلعوا مرسول بيطلعون شركات
ثانيه
وقتها يبغون يكون في صناديق ما مو بوقتها
نجي نقول
نحتاج صناديق
فما اتفق بالعكس اشوف انه بيبدا خلال
الفتره القادمه ان شاء الله بيصير في
صناديق متخصصه لهذا السبب احنا اول صندوق
في المنطقه في الفنتك
متخصص في الفندق
صندوق متخصص في مسرعه اعمال في المنطقه
الشرقيه تخصصها بتقنيات الحيويه البايوتك
واعتقد بتبدا تظهر صناديق متخصصه في هذه
المجالات حلو
الفتره الماضيه وش قاعد تصير في السوق
الحين تنزل تقييماتها في صعوبه في رواد
العماني القنف بحسهم فلوس مستثمرين وش
الاشكاليه اللي صار في السوق اليوم وفي اي
مرحله مرحله الشركات المشكله بشكل اكبر
المشكله اكبر من تحتاج وحده اقتصادي
يجاوبك
بشكل مبسط ومش شرط
في تخوف الناس ما يعرف المرحله الجايه شو
يصير فيها هالمرحله الجايه بنشوف الاسواق
العالميه بتصعد نفس الصعود الاول فيك في
الكاش اللي غير مستخدم عند الصناديق
الاستثماريه واصل ارقام قياسيه مرعبه على
الارقام ولكن كل احد خائف يقول لك انا ما
ادري هل احنا بندخل في كساد هل احنا بندخل
في تباط اقتصادي هل في ازمه اقتصاديه كل
احد خائف ولكن مجبرين يستثمرون عشان مده
الاستثمار لكل صندوق غير مستثمرات طبعا
فتلاحظ انهم نشيطين ولكن صغروا حجم التكت
اللي استثمرونه اللي كان يعطيك عشره صار
يعطيك واحد ونص اثنين والسبب انه يبغى
يكون له رجل ولكن ما يبغى
يكون سيء في حال لا قدر الله يكثر
الاستثمارات بدل ما يكون العدد لكن يقلل
خلينا نقول يقلل احتماليه فشله ولو فشلت
الشركه ما يصير بالعشره صندوق الناس اللي
من مستثمرين وملزمين يصرفون او يستثمرون
مبالغ خلال فتره زمنيه معينه صحيح فهو
بدال ما يصير يصرفها على سبيل المثال على
عشره شركات خمس سنوات مجرد مثل يصير
يصرفها مثلا على 30 شركه يعني
لكن هو ينتظر الوقت يرجع فاذا رجع بيرجع
يكتب شيء يخليه يصغرها
استثمارات هذه المؤثر الحين يمكن تقييمات
جزء كبير منها فتخوف الناس وليس هذا هذا
هذا اثر وليس السبب السبب مثل ما قلنا
تخوف الناس من الاقتصادات الاقتصادات بشكل
عام ما حد يدري وين رايح السوق ارتفاع
نسبه الفائده والى اخره من التفاصيل هذه
كلها اللي قاعده تخوف المستثمرين من
الدخول في تقييمات عاليه جالسين يطلبون
تخفيضات على التقييمات مقابل انهم يمولونك
المبالغ حلو حلو هل هذا العلاقه بالعاده
استثماريه ولا بعض النظر عن الوضع
الاقتصادي بيحتاجون مساعده في مرحله مرحله
ما من احد يحتاج مساعده مساعدتي ومساعده
غيري يعني لا في شركات جوك ما اقدر اقفلون
جرس
شوف اكثر ناس تاثروا بالوضع الحالي هم
الناس اللي في المراحل
او المراحل الاوليه لسه مستمره
والاستثمارات فيها يمكن خف التقييمات شوي
كانت ارقام مجنونه في اخر سنتين غير منطقي
واحد بفكره يقييم 50 مليون دولار الان لا
شوي رجعت للواقع الى حد ما
اغلب الشركات الاثرت هي في جوله الف جوله
باء اللي هي المراحل المتوسطه المراحل
اللي في الشركات المراحل الاخيره المتاخره
قادر انها تجمع رؤوس اموال لان وقتها اما
هو البزنس حقيقي ولا البزنس سيء اصلا
فعندهم تاثير كبير جدا في التقييمات هم
ايضا ولكن ما عنده مشكله في الحصول على
فالمرحله الاوليه
كثير
عشان يقدر ينمي الشركه توصل للمرحله ولا
البي مثلا هنا يحتاج مبلغ اكبر عشان يقدر
يوصل للشركه
الربحيه حق الشركات المتاخره
فالناس اللي تواصلوا معي او الشركات اللي
تواصلت معي
وساعدتهم في كثير تواصلوا معي وللاسف ما
قدرت سواء الوقت او سواء لعدم خبره او
رغبه او فاهم في المجال حتى ما افهم مجالك
يجوني في البدايه يقولون نبغىك تساعدنا
نحصل على جوله استثماريه
ممتاز واضح
هم فعليا يبغون كاش
اول خيار بالنسبه لهم نبغى نبيع حصه مقابل
ان احنا ناخذ استثمار بس الجوله
الاستثماريه
اجلس معاهم واطلب منهم بعض المعلومات بعض
المعلومات الماليه
واشوف السوق
اذا هو بدا يربح او قريب من الربحيه
ما يسوي له جوله استثماريه مقابل حصه
ملكيه
او عفوا جوله تمويليه
ممكن نجمع له مبلغ تسوي فيه قرض
ممكن
في خيارات كثيره يحصل فيها رائد الاعمال
والشركه في المراحل المتوسطه مراحل متاخره
على راس المال بدون ما
يبيع حصه فيها ويتقل نسبه ملكيه
الناس اللي في المرحله الاوليه يبيعون حصص
صحيح لان لسه البزنس اصلا غير قادره على
تحمل
فيتحدد الموضوع هنا
في بعض الاشخاص يقول لك لا انا ما عندي
الرغبه اني ادخل فيديو او الهيكله انت
بتسويها في
ابوظبي ولا بتسويها في الرياض ما تناسبنا
فنفضل نحن بحصص في اشخاص كل شخص كل مؤسس
وتفضيلاته لكن في اكثر من خيار والناس ما
زالت تعتقد انه فقط بحصه مقابل
حصه ولا انهم يجيب
خلينا نقول
ارقامهم الماليه بشكل كبير يحددوش بالنسبه
لهم ممكن تضرب مثال وش اللي يخليه مثلا
الافضل اذا هو على وجه الربحيه خلال سته
شهور خلال ست شهور خلاص بيبدا يدخل في
ربحيه
وما يحتاج مبلغ ضخم جدا
ونمو الربحيه حق واضح الى درجه انه ربحيته
راح تسدد نسبه القرض ونسبه المرابحه
ومع ذلك تظل الشركه مستمره في النمو ليش
تبيع حصتك انت جاهز الاخر اذا راح اخذ نفس
المبلغ ولكن فعليا ما عنده القدره معناها
غالبا راح يصعب عليها الموضوع ليش راح
ياخذ قرض بكره بيضطر يسوي جوله استثماريه
ثانيه يبيع حصه اغلب المستثمرين بيقول لك
بحصه عشان تاخذ فلوس تسدد القرض اللي
اخذته
فتوقيتها يختلف من شركه الى شركه وتقييم
الشركه كيف ياثر على قدرتهم على انهم
يجيبون فلوس لان في ناس قد جابوا العيد في
شركاتهم بسبب التقييمات اللي يحددونها في
كل الجوله
فكيف اثرها على الجوله الاستثماريه يفرق
في اي مرحله في مراحل اوليه والمراحل
المتوسط
لازم يستوعب انه اذا يبغى الصناديق
والمستثمرين يساعدونه
معناها لازم يكون عندهم ربح واضح
على سبيل المثال اذا احنا نعي من الفرصه
الاستثماريه الف ما راح تتخطى 200 مليون
دولار كتقييم
وتجي انت في الجوله الاولى وتقول انا
تقييمي عشرين مليون معناها المستثمر في
افضل احواله لو ما سويت اي جوله استثماريه
وصلت لل 200 مليون طلع عشره ضعف خلال خمس
سنوات مثلا
في فرصه ثانيه هو يقدر يدخل فيها
سقفها ممكن يكون مليار
فبيحصل على عائد اكبر بكثير من اللي انت
عرضته هذا واحد
فالطريقه المثلى هي محاوله الوصول الى
تسعير تقييم
[موسيقى]
متى اتوقع التخرج الى اخره لكن لو نرجع
المراحل المتوسطه يعتمد على نسبه النمو
بشكل كبير جدا نسبه النمو من مراحل
الاوليه الى المرحله اللي انت وصلت لها
وجود المنافسه مما يعني يسمون البارير هل
سهل اي احد يقدر ينافسك ولا عندك خليني
شيء يميزك
تساعدك انك تسبق اي شخص يدخل يحاول يناسبك
في السوق
بالاضافه الى جذبك او المواهب اللي
بتوظفها في ناس كثير تغفل عن دور هذا
الجانب في رفع تقييم الشركات لانه اذا جاك
مستثمر بيكون جوله الف على سبيل المثال
بيعطيك 15 مليون على تقييم خمسين مثال
اعتباطي جدا وباخذ 30%
غالبا عنده استعداد انه يرفعها الى 60
التقييم لو لاحظ ان الموظفين اللي جالس
تجيبهم راح يستفيدون وعندهم قدره كبيره
جدا
الحصول على فائده مقابل 15 مليون دولار
مقارنه بشخص ما عنده الخبره بيتعلم فيها
فغالبا راح يخسر خمسه منها وبيستفيد من
العشره اللي بعده فوجود مواهب وجود موظفين
عندهم خبره سابقه او مرشدين او حتى
مستشارين ادفايزرز او مستشارين وغيره راح
يساعدك لانه في كثير من الاحيان ما تقدر
توظف الاشخاص اللي في بالك حلو
يرفعون تقييمهم بشكل كبير جدا على الاقل
المراحل المتوسطه ولا قدروا يحصلونه حتى
يمكن نزل التقييم الى اقل من النص او اكثر
فهذا كان مرتبط بالكلام ايضا ولا له علاقه
بالسوق ولا وش اللي انت موجود خبره عندهم
عجز موجود مرشدين عدم وجود تجارب سابقه
عدم وجود خبره مع شويه طمع
خلاه يطلب ارقام غير منطقيه
تحس فيه صاير زي السباق على اعلان
الجوالات الاستثماريه طبيعي كل واحد يبغى
يكبر
وش اللي يسهل لك الجوله اللي بعده ولا
ثلاثه اشياء اذا خلينا نقول مبدئيا
توقعاتي بتكون الشغله الاولى هي
مستثمرين في المراحل اللي بعدها اسمعوا
عنك قبل كذا
النقطه الثانيه يدرون ان في شركه اللي
مهتم بالقطاع اللي انت تشتغل فيه غالبا
بيتابعك الين ينتظرك وممكن اذا سمع اخبار
حلوه كثير عنك من السوق يتواصل معك فهذا
جانب وهو منطقي جدا الجانب الثاني اعتقد
يسهل الحصول على تايلند مواهب شركه
الاشخاص بيحسون ان هذه الشركه جماعه جوله
الاستثماريه كبيره
بحس بالامانه انا انظر لها بدل الجزء
الاخير اللي هو موجود في كل شخص كل البشره
الرغبه بالظهور كشخص ناجح يعني
تجذب الدعم سواء من جهه الحكوميه بتاع خاص
مسرعات شبكات اللي شاف والله جابوا جوله
الاستثماريه كبيره هذه تفيده بشكل كبير
[موسيقى]
استخدام الكفاءات برضو الشركات ماشيه تحفز
تحفزهم من خلال تعطيهم اسهم صحيح تحس في
مشكله في السوق اليوم انه الكفاءة ياخذون
نفسه
وش الوضع
يعني كثير من الشركات تخصص تقريبا ما
يقارب 10% من اسهمها بعد جوله الف بحيث
انها تعطى للموظفين وتسمونها
اختصار
فالموظفين عاده في المراحل الاوليه
خل نفرض شخص راتبه ثلاثين الف وبيروح ينظم
الى شركه ستارتب
وبيعطونا راتب
تجتمع تقريبا سنويا يصير قيمتها 96
بما قيمه تقريبا 120 130 الف ريال على امل
ان خلال السنوات القادمه يزيدون راتبه
التصاعديا يزيد من 22 ل 25 الى 30 في
المثال هذا وقيمه الاسهم هذه لقيمتها 150
خلينا نقول اعطاه اياها تزيد الى
34500,000 مع نمو تقييم الشركه
ولاحظنا في امثله كثيره جدا لخروج كثير من
رواد الاعمال بره حتى في السعوديه وفي
المنطقه الحمد لله يبيعون الحصص وقت
التخارج ويحصلون على عوائد بالملايين لكن
ممكن اذا فشلت شركه تتبخر هذه ما لها اي
قيمه بس على الاقل
انك مساهمتك في الشركه هذه
بالضبط انه ممكن يجيب لك عائد اكبر انك
تكون ملتزم او تحصل على فقط بس ما في ما
في الان يمكن وضوح كبير في قيمه الاسهم
هذه للموظفين
مثلا خمسين سنه بس ما يدري خمسين كبير جدا
على مؤسسين الشركات انه يوضحون تقييم
الشركه في كل جوله استثماريه او في كل
مرحله يتم فيها تقييم الشركه
وتم عن طريق مشاركه سعر السهم هذيك اللحظه
ما يساعد الموظف على حساب المبالغ طبعا
طبعا فيها حسبه طويله هي وفي اكثر موضوع
متشعب في مجموعه كورسات اونلاين انا صراحه
افضل ان الاشخاص ياخذونها قبل ما يوافقون
على العروض عشان يعرفونهم مش داخلين عليه
لانه فيها تفاصيل كثيره وفيها تقسيمات
كبيره وغير مجدي بالنسبه لك انك تجيب
محامي علشان عقد وظيفي
الدورات موجوده اونلاين موجوده ببلاش
لتبحث في ايديكس لو تبحث في تبحث فيه
كيف هي كيف تنحسب وش افضل سيناريو طبعا في
اسواق اخرى غير المنطقه
الشركات غالبا كل سته شهور او كل تسعه
شهور او كل سنه تجمع الموظفين اللي دخلوا
خلال الفتره هذه تحطوهم في جدول ترفع
المجلس الاداره هذه عروضهم هذي اللي
وافقوا عليه بناء على اليه التوزيع اللي
وافق عليها المجلس من الاساس اصلا
ياخذونها الموظفين يوافقون مجلس الاداره
عليها تيجي العقود لك كموظف توقعها مو من
اول يوم على طول
المفروض من تاريخ الانضمام الى نهايه اول
سنه اذا طلعت ما تستحق ولا شيء في اكثر من
هيكله لها ولكن اكثر واحده مشهوره هي اللي
ذكرتها انت خلينا
نفرض انك انت اخذت اسهم بقيمه 48 الف
دولار على اربع سنوات بمعنى انك تاخذ 12
الف سنه السنه الاولى ما راح تحصل على اي
شيء الا بنهايه السنه الاولى كامله بتحصل
على 12,000 بعد ما تكمل سنه ويوم بعدها
تاخذ السنه الثانيه والسنه الثالثه والسنه
الرابعه تاخذها بشكل شهري تاخذ الف
بانتهاء كل شهر من بدايه لقياس جديه
الموظف انه ما راح اقدر اوزع من كل واحد
يجرب انا لو اعطيته لو عطيتك الاسهم في
اول سنه واستقال بعد سته شهور
هي تستخدم
للموظفين مع الوضع الحالي تشوف وقت مناسب
انه الواحد يبدا الشركه الان
اليوم
في حجم الفرصه كبيره جدا بس قبل شركات
تقنيه فرصه كبيره جدا يعني دائما انا
اقيسها شخصيا بطريقه واحده هل انت راضي عن
الخدمات كلها تتقدم لك انت معناها توجد
فرصه للتطوير بالاضافه لان مثل ما ذكرنا
قدرت تبني منتج وفريق افضل من غيرها لان
ما كان عندها وفره في المال انها تصير تحل
مشاكلها بانها تحرق مبالغ الماليه صارت
تحتاج ان تحل مشاكلها فعليا ولما جت
الموجه الجديده وصعد السوق كانوا هم
جاهزين انهم يصلون الى تقييمات
وارقام فلكيه سواء في حجم الجولات
الاستثماريه حجم مبيعاتهم حجم ارباحهم
والتقييمات اللي
يحصلوا مشكله في انه يلقى استثمارات
لانه في وفره سواء في المستثمرين او في
صحيح في الفلوس كثير من الاشخاص متحمسين
هل تعتقد افضل يكثرون المستثمرين الملاكين
في البدايه ولا لا ما فهمت يعني هلو يجي
واحد مثلا يبغى يحتاج مثلا خلينا نقول
100000 مثال يحتاج 100000 عشان يقدر يشتغل
ويكبر الشركه في البدايات هل ياخذها من
واحد ياخذها من عشره يعني
كمثال يخليهم ياخذهم اشخاص متعددين مثلا
متعدد الخبرات ولا انه يقول ابي بس اسرع
شيء يقفل اعطني فلوس خلني اقفله بسرعه حسب
خبرته اذا هو شخص مطلعك ويعتقد هو شركاء
اللي معاه مؤسسين ما ينقصهم بهذيك اللحظه
الا دعم المادي يفضل انه ياخذ اللي يساعده
يطلق المنتج بشكل اسرع اذا يرى في بعض
النقص في بعض الخبرات او بعض المناطق يفضل
ان ياخذ من المستثمرين يساعدونه يغطي هذا
المناظر الجواب ما في جواب واضح ولكن ما
افضل ان يكون عدد كبير جدا يعني
المليون دولار غالبا
سبعه ثمانيه اشخاص كفايه زياده وهذا يمكن
اللي يخلي
في صعوبه في الاستثمار الحصول على
الاستثمار من خلال المنصات التمويل سابقا
اللي كانوا يجونك فجاه كذا 500 مستثمرهم
هم قبيلك فعليا
القانون شوي
مختلف شركه تكون شركه ذات عفوا شركه
مساهمه مغلقه في ريحه مختلفه فكل شخص وحسب
رغبته ممكن ينفع مع المشاريع
شبه تقليديه او تقليديه عندك عشر مطاعم
انت بتفتح عشر فروع زياده خيار جيد جدا
انك تسوي
استثمار استثماريه عن طريق مصاد تمويل
يمثلون في شركه هي اللي تستثمر عندي
الهيكل الجديد اللي صار بس هذا المنطق
وهذا اللي يصير اصلا بره
شركه ذات
غرض خاصه
وتستثمر في جميع يستثمر فيها من
المستثنيين الافراد والشركه هذه هي اللي
تستثمر فيه الشركه
الرصاص بشرحها بشكل سريع اللي هي خلنا
نقول قانوني يتيح المجموعه مستثمرين
يستثمرون باسم واحد صحيح ويصير في واحد
ممثل مسافرين هو اللي يصير فيه
تواصلات حتى يسوونها احيانا للمستثمرين
اللي يقول لك انت عندك مبلغ بسيط استثمر
فيه بس انا راغب فيك خلاص ادخل من خلال
هذه القانوني
والباقيين لاي احد يدخل فوق مبلغ معين
خلاص تعال تستثمر بشكل مباشر
وتكون علاقه مباشره معك ليش ما يبغون
يكثرون اسماء الناس المستثمرين معاهم بشكل
مباشر
العالم صعبه يعني
بتصير لو تبغى تغير شغله خلينا نقول تبي
نظام الشركه تحتاج تتواصل معاه المئه
مستثمر لا تخلوه معك كل واحد فيهم حط الف
دولار ولا الف دولار انه يكون في شخص عنده
القدره النائيه هذا الشيء ويتخذ القرار
بالنيابه فانتاج تدير العدد صحيح في ناس
المباشرين اللي هم الاكبر استثمار وقيمه
في ناس من خلال مثلا
وين شايف الترند الحالي في السوق يعني
تكلمنا مثلا زي ادفع لاحقا كان ترند حقه
كم قبل سنتين ثلاثه
الجديد الحين او الاشياء الجديده على حسب
متى بتطلع الحلقه يعني ههه
لكن في فرص كبيره جدا الان اعتقد في موضوع
الاقراض
قطاع البي تو بي اذا بتكلم عن التقنيات
الماليه بشكل ادق ونشمل تحتها تقنيات
العقاريه وتقنيات التامينيه هذه فيها فرص
كبيره قطاع الاعمال البي تو بي في
التقنيات الماليه فيه نقص مرعب يعني
اساسيات البزنس ناقص اليوم اذا تفتح متجر
الكتروني الانظمه المحاسبيه اللي موجوده
كخدمات سوفت وير من وجهه نظري الشخصيه ما
ترقى الى الى مستوى جوده منصات التي تفتح
لك متاجر الكترونيه باستثناء يمكن شركه او
شركتين فقط وحجم الفرصه ضخمه جدا
فاعتقد ان في قطاع الاعمال تقنيات الملك
قطاع الاعمال قطعه ساقين التقنيات
التامينيه
اعتقد خلال السنتين ثلاث سنوات القادمه
بيكون في انفجار كبير جدا
لانه الى الان ما بعد وش فكرهتها زي يا
شباب في مثل
تاميني سوت العجل صارت الجمع وتقدر تشوف
والعمليه جميله جدا كانت ما شاء الله من
تجربه انا مبهور صراحه من منبهر بالتجربه
اللي هم يقدروا يسوونها ما شاء الله عليهم
الشباب وموفقين لكن في قطاعات ثانيه انت
الان عندك مشكله لا قدر لا قدر الله صار
لك حادث موضوع التعويضات موضوع بعد
السيارات مرني يحل جزء من السلسله هذه لكن
الفرصه كبيره جدا بالاضافه الى ان كل وحده
منها المراحل تعتبر فرصه ضخمه تامين على
الحياه تامين على السيارات التامين على
البيت تامين على المعداتك
اليوم اللي هو لاحقا موجود ثابته كم شركه
ثانيه موجودين من الشباب الله يعطيهم
العافيه على على الافراد طب قطاع الاعمال
ما زال مرعب الموضوع فيه ما حد قاعد يقدم
حلول واضحه وصل الى حجم مساوي اللي يملكوه
شركات الاخرى تقطاع الافراد بس
يكون
مواجه للناس اكثر فيه يمكن واجهها اكثر
ولا مو طبيعي حجم التركز في قطاع الافراد
والنقص اللي موجود فيه قطاع الاعمال
لان جزء كبير من
تجاره كانت فتره طويله قطاع الافراد وقطاع
الحكومي
ما بين قطاع التجاري والحكومي التجاري
والافراد البي تو بي الان مع جهود وغيرها
من الشركات او عفوا الصناديق جلسه جالسه
تتطور جوده الخدمات اللي يقدمونها فصار
عندهم حلول يحتاجونها غير موجوده في السوق
الان بدات الفرصه تظهر بشكل اكبر هذا جانب
الجانب الثاني
عدد الموظفين اللي سبق لهم العمل في قطاع
البي تو سي اللي هو قطاع الافراد او قطاع
الحكومي او القطاع التجاري الحكومي اكبر
من عدد الاشخاص
يعني الناس بحكم احتكاكهم بشكل كبير مع
الخدمات يصير في عدد اكبر من الناس اللي
يتحمسون زيها
عدد قليل جدا من الناس نسبيين اللي محتكين
فيه اعتقد لو تسال اغرب الاشخاص اللي
يتعاملون مع الافراد يقول لك
ثاني اتعامل معهم ما بتعامل مع الحفل
يستخدمونه يبغى عمه الناس يتكلمون عنه
يبغى يكون في الواجهه ما يبغى ممل مقارنه
مدفون مره في شركات حتى من ضمنها مثلا
ساري وشركه ثانيه ناجحه في البي تو بي بس
قد يواجهون مثلا صعوبه في التوظيف لانه ما
حد يدعمه صحيح
فقد تكون اسباب تساهم ايضا كثيره اعتقد
وما يمدينا نحصرها ولكن وجهه نظري عدم
وجود اشخاص يعني قبل ساري انا وانت ما
اشتغلنا في قطاع
لكن بعدها اكتشفنا انه طيب الان في فرصه
في القطاع هذا في على سبيل المثال
نمت 16 ضعف في
12 شهر فقط
من ناحيه مبيعات من ناحيه تقييمات موضوع
مرعب والسبب
تبيع
وتشتري فواتيرك اللي موجوده عند
تتعامل معهم
خدمه يسوونها البنوك على
الصناديق لكن على على حجم كبير جدا الحجم
متوسط والصغير ما حد كان يسويه فهو دخل
لحل هذا المشكل ودي بعد ما تكلمنا عن
المستثمرين رواد العمال والترند اللي
رايحين الان انت دخلت في مجموعه شركات
كانت ناجحه جدا وماشيه مع الترند وقتها
وحتى في رواد اعمال المتميزين جدا هم اللي
كانوا يقولون للشركات هذه وغالبا الفرص
هذه هي اللي تجيك ما هي باللي انت اللي
تروح تدورها وتلقاها فكيف قدرت توصل
لشركات زي مثلا ساري
الاستمارات هذه ساري تمارا مجموعه الشركات
سله في مجموعه شركات متميزه جدا ونمت نمو
هائل جدا
غالبا اي شخص مجرد انه يتم فيها ما راح
يحصل فرص زي ما زي ما جتك هي بنفسها
وشلون تفورتلك الحمد لله رب العالمين
توفقت انا في مجموعه بتكلم يمكن عن
الشركات اللي في المنطقه بحيث ان المجتمع
يكون عارف بالشركات لو ذكرت لك الشركات في
الهند وفي امريكا يمكن ما تكون معروفه
فعلى سبيل المثال ساري رين تمارا سله انا
كنت عضو مجلس اداره لكن ما كنت مستثمر مع
الشركه عضو مجلس دار مستقل
اذا بنتكلم على سبيل المثال على ساري
لا
عضو مجلس اداره مستقل تقريبا اربع سنوات
لكن
على سبيل المثال
لاني انا شخص جاهز وجالس اتكلم على
الاستثمار وجالس احاول استثمر وكنت في
امريكا في ذيك اللحظه تواصل معاي احد
الاصدقاء وقال لي
في شركه عندنا في المسرع لازم تقابلها كنت
بشكل دوري اشوف كل الشركات اللي يخرجونها
من مسرع ولكن قال يقابلهم الان فلما
قابلتهم
اعجبني محمد الدوسري هذاك الوقت رؤيته وين
يبي يروح حجم الفرصه حجم السوق فاستثمرت
معه ولكن هدف رئيسي جاهز لهذا السبب
والناس تعرف اني انا مستعد استثمر بشكل
سريع وبعطيك الاجابه ايه ولا لا الان
بالاضافه للنقطه الاخيره اللي هي اني انا
جالس اتكلم واقول يا جماعه الخير هذه
القطاعات انا احبها هذه اشياء انا افضلها
خلونا نستثمر فيها بشكل اكبر فصار
خليني اقول مجتمع اللي حولي اذا لقى فرصه
استثماريه يجي يقول لي شوف هذه الفرصه
موجوده هنا هل هذا في موضوع التغريدات
تكتب صحيح البدايه كانت حساب تويتر
مشاركتي للمعلومات في بعض القطاعات وساعد
الشيء هذا الناس تفهم انا وش ابغى وتفهم
وين تركيزي من صدفه اذا جاء احد يقولوا
لنا تبحث عن هذا الشخص او شخص بالشكل
الفلاني توجه له تسويق لنفسك هنا صحيح
بشكل مع نشر الفائده والمعلومات
قصتها جميله انا كنت في
بحكم اني كنت اكتب تغريدات عن قطاع
التقنيات الماليه وهذيك الفتره
وكنت ذاكر في حسابي اني انا استثمر فيه
تقطع تقنيات الماليه هذه المره احد
المؤسسين بحث في لندن ما لقى بحث فيه
تويتر لقاني وارسل لي رساله خاصه وقال
احنا عندنا المشروع الفلاني ودي اجلس معك
وينك انا في الانف
وطلع في حي قريب مني جلست معاه لان كان
عندي خبره على الموضوع خلينا نقول باقل من
50% اربعين خمسين في المئه بالكثير لكن
حسيت انه في فرصه كبيره ولحظه كنت فيه
واستوعبت ان هذا نموذج جالس يكبر بينتشر
لاحقا في اسواق ثانيه
دخلت مع الشباب
تمارا على سبيل المثال
تواصل معي عبد المجيد لاني قابلته
سابقا كان يشتغل في شركه سابقه في نعناع
تعرفت عليه هناك كان كان هو رئيس تنفيذ
القطاع المالي وكان شريك مؤسس تعرفت عليه
عن طريق احد المؤتمرات اللي سواها
كلمني قال اشوفك تستثمر يمين ويسار في
الفنتك وان انا جالس ابني منتج فنتك وانا
صرت اعرف الرجل عرفت وش سوى في التجربه
السابقه فاستثمرت معه فكثير منها كانت لمه
على سبيل المثال ايضا جت عن طريق مستثمر
في البحرين لان هو بدا الشركه في البحرين
وكان عنده رغبه انه ينقلها للسعوديه فقال
له اذا تبغى تدخل السوق السعودي في قطاع
تقنيات الماليه نفضل انك تبدا مع مستثمرين
في قطاع التقنيات الماليه فربطني فيه
وجلست معاه واستثمرت
فجزء كبير من القصه انك انت تكون جاهز
وهذي استراتيجيه اللي انا استخدمها اطور
نفسي في المجال بشكل مستمر تقاطع مع الناس
اقرا فيه اقرا اخبار اتابع وش يصير فيه في
الاسواق وعلى فكره هنا احيانا تصل الى
مرحله انك تقول ليش ما في احد يسوي
الموضوع الفلاني تكتشف انت انه في فراغ في
السوق تروح تبحث عن شركات تعبي الفراغ
ممكن تلقاهم ممكن تكتشف انه في اشياء يعني
ناس تسقط عليهم فجاه
لانهم يسولفون بتويتر ولا لنا يعني
الرجال في نيويورك
كنت أسالة مصعب توقعت
تغريد
وتكلمني
في 2018 2019 لغايه متابعه يمكن 95% من
الاشخاص اللي عندك عفوا في تويتر وقررت
اني اتابع الاشخاص اللي ممكن يفيدوني في
قطاع الاستثمار الجريء واستثمار الملائكه
لو تدخل عندي حساب تويتر دائما عندي حد
مستحيل اوصل ل 1000 متابع مستحيل اتابع
اكثر من الف شخص مستحيل لانه بعدها افقد
السيطره ما عاد اقدر فدائما تلقاهم 940
950 960 اذا تابعت احد جديد ولفت انتباهي
اروح ابحث عن الاشخاص اللي انا تابعتهم هل
في احد يقدم معلومات ولا اشيله فقاعدت
ابني
جدول المتابعين هذا اللي يصل تقريبا لالف
شخص
اما هم اشخاص ناجحين انهم اشخاص يملكون
مجتمعات استثماريه مثل هذا الشخص اللي في
نيويورك مايكل
كان هو يدير مجتمع استثماريه فكان يسولف
دائما على الاستثمار في نيويورك حجم الفرص
في التقنيات الماليه في نيويورك وكذا انا
وصلت له عن طريق تقنيات الماليه حجم الفرص
حجم الفرص فمره مرات قال اني انا بسوي
صندوق ارسلت لك السلام عليكم
واستثمرت اول شيء مع مجموعه من الشركات في
الصندوق عنده بشكل مباشر بعدين دخلت في
الصندوق بشكل
كمستثمر في الصندوق نفسه
فاستخدم تويتر بشكل كبير جدا في شركه ايضا
في اسمها كان مايكرو اكواير غيروها الان
اكواير
جالس الرجال يتكلم انه ليش ما في منصه
منصه تبيع المشاريع
انت تبني مشروعك مو لازم يصير تقييم عشره
مليار ولم يتم مليان ولا انت مشروع صغير
حجمه 400 الف دولار
فهو يسولف ليش ارسلت له
فكره ممتازه مين بسويها قال انا جالس
ابنيها وجالس احاول اجمع من الناس سبب عدم
وجود هذا الفكره
فقلت له اذا بتسويها انا بدخل معك
جوله استثماريه قال الان جالس اسوي جوله
استثماريه وهذولي مجموعه المستثمرين اللي
مستثمرين معي كان من ضمنهم نابال مثلا
مؤسس انجلست
بالاضافه اللي مجموعه صناديق واحد من عفوا
مجموعه مستثمره لكن واحد منهم
قابلته في سابقا فارسلت له قلت تعرف هذا
الرجال قال يعرف قلت هل جالس
يلعب قال لا فعلا جالس ابني واحد اثنين
ثلاثه واحنا راجعناه انا واكس
فكلمتك قلت له يلا انا بدخل معك
فاستخدم تويتر بشكل كبير جدا
للحصول على معلومات السوق وين رايح بعض
الفرص اللي انا بعيد عنها في في مناطقة
تحاول تقنعون جاهزين في البدايات كانت
صعبه الان بعد ما تعديت خمسين ستين شركه
صار صار قبولهم اسرع بكثير صار فيه خلاص
شركتين واحده اخذت سنتين وقفلت والثانيه
دخلت في التقنيات التسويقيه اجن بحكم عدم
وجود خبره قديمه خبرتي في موضوع التسويق
فشلت للاسف فيها
في شركات
للاسف كانت ناجحه
ومؤسسيها قتلوها لانها تحولت الى
صار مشروع جانبي يعتقد ان النجاح بيدوم
فمات المشروع بعد ما احمله
نقل المدينه ثانيه اكبر باع شويه من الحصه
اللي عنده وصار عايش حياه عايش حياه
الوناسه بدا يموت تدريجيا
وهذا يتكرر كثير لهذا السبب كثير من
الصناديق الاستثماريه تحط شرط انها تقدر
تجبر انك تبيع وتتخذ اجراء محدد في حال
تحول مشروع الى مشروع جاري
مجلس الاداره يقرش مع وجود
على سبيل المثال تخيل انك تملك شركه في
الرياض جمعت جوله الاستثماريه مئه مليون
دولار والامور طيبه ومبيعاتك مليار دولار
والحياه حلوه رحت بعت عن جزء من حصتك
بخمسه مليار ريال او خمسه مليون دولار
عفوا
الرياض حطت الموضوع تجيهم انت مره في
الشهر صارت واضحه يبدا مجلس اداره يسالك
عن التفاصيل ما تعرف السي فو يبداع في
المثال الاعتباطي هذا هو الايجابي يبدو
يلاحظون يمكن نقطه في ناس كثير تخفى عنهم
انه فعليا لا المستثمر ولا
رائد الاعمال يحتاج ينتظر ليه ما تنباع
الشركه عشان تطلع فلوس من خلال الجوله
الاستثماريه
للمستثمر يقدر يبيع حصته كامله
استثماريه ويطلعلك كاش محترم صحيح ويعيش
خلينا نقول شيء سلبي جدا واشاره سلبيه جدا
صناديق الاستثماريه والمستثمرين انه يبيع
حصه في البدايات لان معناها انه بجد جالس
هو مؤمن بالفكره وبالتسارع وبالخطه اللوحه
حاطه معناه اقل من 12 18 شهر ممكن هذا
المبلغ يكون عشره اضعاف فمن سيريس بي جوله
باء وجوله جيم يبدا منطق انه يبيع نصف في
المئه واحد في المئه وهو عرفه متعارف عليه
ويصير كثير يسلم الاقل يطلع له تحسين وضعك
اللي بيتزوج اللي بيشتري سياره اللي عندك
ديون تبي تسددها بحيث انك تكون مرتاح وانت
جالس تبني هذا الكيان
خلاص ما مشت امورهم
يعطيك العافيه نرسل يعني في واحد منهم
للاسف اختفى ما ادري الا اليوم ما ادري هو
لكن البزنس قفل
لكن الباقيين يرسلون ترى يا جماعه الخير
فشلنا واحد اثنين ثلاثه اربعه فعليا في
اثنين من اللي افلسوا يرجع في شركات ثانيه
ليش الايميلات والتقارير اللي ارسلت لسبب
فشلهم كانت مقنعه اكثر من اي شيء ثاني في
الحياه الى درجه ان
تفهم ان الشخص هذا تعلم من اخطائه كان
صادق ما كذب
وبعضهم يفشل ترى مو بالسوق احيانا يتجه
الى مرحله
في موضوع الاستثمار في الشركات احتمال
كبير او الاصل اصلا انك فلوسك هذه بتروح
بعد هي موجوده بتقفل الشركه ولا تاخذ
الموضوع بشخصنا انه صراحه
في بعض المستثمرين خاصه من عقار كتابة
مئه بالمئه راس مال الوحيد عنده اعتقد هذه
المشكله بس ما يصير مجدي الين الاستثمار
يعني هذا النوع من الاصول الين ما تتعدى
عدد معين من الشركات ممكن 20 30 شركه لازم
تستثمر الدخل الفائض اللي عندك اللي ما
تحتاجه بعد ما تكون اسست حياتك لو بشكل
مبلغ اللي بيستثمروا بالشركه هذه قصدي غير
مجدي انك مثلا تستثمر
في شركه واحده
وان شاء الله يا رب ما يزيد يسوق الاسهم
تكبر على شركات تستثمر فيها عشرين ثلاثين
شركه
الاوليه
تكبر العدد لانه يمكن واحده تضرب ولا
ثنتين وتعوض عن الباقي عادي بس عشان الناس
اللي مجمع له تحويشه
شركه واحده الله يعطيك العافيه مصعب
استمتع معك اليوم
فوق 1818 شركه خلصنا دجاج
شكرا لك شكرا لكم حياك الله قبل ما تقفل
الحلقه اتمنى اذا عجبتك تشاركها مع اللي
حولك وتقيمها بتقييم ايجابي سواء في
اليوتيوب او في ايتونز واذا كان عندكم
ملاحظات عنها ياليتك تشاركني اياها سواء
على ايميل البرنامج سوالف ات 8.com او حتى
على حسابي في تويتر
شكرا لمتابعتكم وشكرا لعبد الملك ال سعيد
في اعداد الحلقه ياسر الغانم في اداره
التصوير بالاضاءه غالب محمد ومساعده الي
في الاخراج الابداعي وهاب موسى في الاخراج
الفني مجد القرشي في الهندسه الصوتيه عبد
العزيز المزي في التحرير برامج بيبان في
التجهيز عبد المجيد عمر عبد الله بن
الفقيه محمد عبد العزيز وفي الانتاج
التنفيذي رزاند هيثم هذا
منتجات شركه 8 للنشر والتوزيع